[Music]
[Singing] Who's the guy who fights by keeping
garbage cans clean?
And who's the lucky Joe they picked to
dig the latrine?
Oh, he's your Uncle's favorite fighting Marine!
McGillicuddy!
Who'd like to get his hands upon that lady
marine?
Who released him for duty in a horse's latrine?
It's that chambermaid commando, that fighting marine,
McGillicuddy! [End of singing]
[Narrator:] But he's not the only one. All the guys have
dirty jobs to do and a smart guy will take
a bath whenever he can find clean water.
These men want to get the dirt, germs, and
sweat off their skin,
and a bath is the best method.
But not McGillicuddy! He doesn't like to take
a bath. He's allergic to water.
[Flies are buzzing  around McGillicuddy. A skunk comes out to sniff him but quickly runs away.]
[A silhouetted soldier plays a bugel to awaken the soldiers at sunrise.]
[McGillicuddy wakes up scratching his body.]
[Narrator:] Uh huh, the first signs of the itch. The skin
you love to scratch.
[McGillicuddy takes off his socks and throws them at the wall, where they stick.]
[The socks unstick themselves and back away when McGillicuddy tries to grab them; he chases them.]
[McGillicuddy catches his socks after they
surrender in defeat.]
[McGillicuddy's in bed but his feet are covered in rashes and he continuously scratches them.]
[As McGillicuddy sleeps, germs chip and saw away at his feet, making the rash worse.]
[Bugel plays and soldiers march.]
[Narrator:] Well, McGillicuddy! After a good night's sleep, fresh as a daisy!
[Daisies wilt with McGillicuddy near.]
[Narrator:] Oh, uh, sorry daisies.
[McGillicuddy walks on his hands with feet in the air.]
[Natives pop out from behind trees after McGillicuddy passes.]
[McGillicuddy avoids using his feet; he
swings through the treetops.]
[Natives follow McGillicuddy on the ground.]
[McGillicuddy comes across a sign posted to a tree.]
[Sign is titled Third Commandment: Personal Cleanliness]
[Narrator:] Thou shalt keep thy personal habits clean.
For surely cleanliness is next to Godliness. Dirt and filth are the brothers of discomfort, disease, and death.
[McGillicuddy:] And they ain't kiddin'.
[McGillicuddy's crawling on the ground.]
[McGillicuddy:] Help!
[Natives tie up and carry McGillicuddy away without his shoes.]
[Natives tie McGillicuddy to a tree and stir
a boiling cauldron.]
[Natives hold McGillicuddy above the boiling cauldron.]
[McGillicuddy:] Are, are you gonna eat me?
[Native, laughing:] No, sir! We're gonna give you a bath!
[Natives drop McGillicuddy into cauldron.]